guess we've been hoping to get him on
the air for the last few days and he's
finally graced us with his presence
we've got the founder and president of
the st. Louis chess club Rex Sinquefield
one of my least favorite people in the
world know the guy and everything that
he's done for chess has been simply
wonderful along with his lovely wife dr.
Judy Ziegfeld Rex
always a pleasure to have you on the
show and this events not a lot of
victories but still very exciting no
you're right not a lot of victories but
a lot of action a lot of tension to be
sure everybody feels the tension we'll
see what happens today but first I want
to compliment and thank yasser Jen and
you for the best broadcast of any sport
in the world period I say that all the
time that's only because I know it's
true I appreciate those kind words you
look at the tournament like this when
you see Fabiano you can contextualize it
as you're a fan of bobby fischer's and
seeing us chess yeah blossom during
those years and I usually Fabiano doing
what he's doing let's give you a special
feeling oh I think it's wonderful I
think he's there gonna be a fobby effect
and let's really hope that there's a
Fabia effect in London in November it's
going to be exciting and what's amazing
I was just talking to him before and
after your interview is his composure
it's just always there he's absolutely
remarkable which is a great trait trait
you need if you're gonna compete in this
sport
absolutely you talk about the Fabia fact
the Ziegfeld effect is something that
everyone talks about we have a actual
exhibition over at the world chest all
the fame and talking about that that
must also warm your heart yeah it does I
asked him not to use that name I asked
the staff not to name this tournament
after me and you see how much influence
I have around here basically I'm reduced
to the point where I do what I'm told
they say thank you very much now sit
down what what do you expect to see more
of American chess as the Fabia effect
takes hold and the Sinquefield effects
it I think that well first of all will
expand if it's possible our outreach to
children I mean you know for well
because you've purchased
in a very important way here in 140
schools that were in and we're really
working on I want to see a much better
expansion of the program where police
officers teach chests to the inner-city
children in the inner-city public
schools that's not going as well as I
want it's a wonderful idea and I think
we'll get it going I think it's very
important so I want to see more there
and then I think we gotta look around
see if we can have more of these top
tournaments at worldwide tournaments or
world level tournaments here there's
certainly room for them and in everybody
loves it you know it's the best thing in
chess something else that people love as
we see this on the screen right now
scholastics effect you've had that's
right
the soul of the chess club in the
beautiful world chess Hall of Fame
something that we never expected to be
so lovely the work night your staff is
doing over there as a staff is
unbelievably good they really are we
would have when we brought it to st.
Louis or when the u.s. chess trust
allowed us to take it from Miami I don't
think they knew nor did we know the
levels to which we would take it but our
staff has taken it to a very high level
in fine art tangentially sometimes
connected with chess and in music I mean
it really is a rich cultural center
grounded by the most intellectual sport
in the world and the attendance at all
of these things is truly remarkable
yeah that's an incredible thing they do
over there what a great event the other
day with Nettie Robinson the artists and
then afterwards we all got to paint our
chess pieces I took about an hour and a
half on mine trying to make sure it was
done right and you took all about five
minutes on yours well you know that's
the way Picasso works you just slap some
paint on there right gorgeous chess
pieces that ours will be lacquered and
sent back and I'm actually gonna have my
name connected to you in a concrete way
as working together they're gonna put my
set on auction at Sotheby's or
Christie's I know they will I don't know
about your piece but yours might be sold
at Kmart
ah but it's gonna see about did you do a
queen also I just a king and I'm
thinking oh I lost my train of thought I
do that to people trying to disrespect
you in some kind of way but the the
future of this event as you said you
want to bring more events more miscount
all of the world-class events oh I
remember what I wanted to talk about now
Gary Kasparov is gonna be here that's
right I mean he played last year and
back again this year
you keep getting Gary honor of so-call
retirement I think it's remarkable
I am excited I thought obviously the
whole chess world 12 or 15 million
tournament players in the world or
excited about his coming back and I'm
surprised he came back I'm gratified
that he did after last year you know I
wouldn't have bet that he would have but
I think he's loaded for bear this time
very exciting and man he's only playing
against Apollo if we have some other big
names that will be here as well
September 11 through 14th right that'll
be exciting for this team to come back
and call have you played chess by 60 no
I have not you're gonna have to try it
out in this event no if they want me to
I don't know if they can meet my price
[Music]
well I'm sure they could sneak you in
some way in the back with little Rachel
Lee who probably chopping at the
businesses what is she seven years old
now
thank you very much Maurice I really
appreciate it when you tell the entire
world more than 200 countries millions
of people that I lose to a
seven-year-old girl I approve
now that's the first time I've ever
heard you say that to me yes I can't
believe you just said that you know well
you know the book she wrote and I can't
say it on the air but you know it was
aptly named I'm looking forward to you
losing thank you of course you have been
a wonderful patron that actually the
words
would not be enough with the stuff the
things that you have done for chess in
the United States and the effect you've
had on chess around the world we
appreciate you thank you very much for
all you do thank you and it wouldn't
have happened without the incredible
staff we have all three of you know how
good they are and how hard they work and
they're just amazing and I love the the
rule that seems to be omnipresent all
the chance of camp chess campus the no
jerk role yeah it's just there's never
any negative energy here they don't get
hired if there's that I think that's
also inspired by some of Rex's previous
successes right Rex a statement more of
observation and maybe your reflection on
it
but we had dinner on the Saturday that
was the day that Magnus and favi faced
off the champion and the Challenger
playing here in st. Louis at your club
all the while basking in the knowledge
that America has the gold medal Olympic
winning team and as I was thinking about
it all I was thinking to myself this was
the culmination that particular day was
the culmination of everything you could
have possibly imagined and do you feel
that way or do you think greater heights
are await I think we can do more I think
we've done some wonderful things but
knowing the people I work with
it'll get better every year and people
like you will make it better every year
well that answer thank you
been wonderful it's been I and on my
behalf and and Jen and Maurice I can
tell you very very frankly it's such a
great pleasure to be here at these
historic occasions and it's so fun to
call these events well thank you yeah
sure let me tell you I've got
connections with City Hall so if you'd
like to move here we can facilitate
thank you very much Jen where do we
stand what happened